I do have like a little bit of an edge
Miley Cyrus think Cody Simpson are just
having fun getting used to it over the
weekend the nothing breaks like a heart
singer and the 22 year old Ozzy were
getting cozy on social media
Cody posting this shirtless black and
white snap to his Instagram story while
kissing Miley on the head riding free
swim breakfast
courtesy of baby I'm like the luckiest
ever Miley couldn't help but hilariously
poke fun at Cody's sweet nickname by
sharing a selfie simply captioned baby
with a slew of actual baby pics to
follow the photos come just a day after
Miley took to Twitter to talk about the
double standards surrounding her dating
life writing quote men especially
successful ones are rarely slut-shamed
they move on from one beautiful young
woman to the next most times without
consequence Liberty Road girl and though
the singer recently split with Caitlin
Carter as well as separated from her
strange husband Liam Hemsworth a source
told et on Friday that Cyrus and Simpson
have no plans to start dating just keep
on living you know the lifestyle that
I'm living I love it well Miley and Cody
have been friends for years they've
hooked up in the past they both just
wanted to have fun and are open and
honest with each other about that adding
Miley and Cody talked to each other
about everything they're very close and
feel comfortable sharing details with
each other about their lives
[Music]